we looked at the vid all the obstacles
that have gone into making mental health
solutions not part of the founder
mentality and its stigma and cost and
scarcity of quality therapists and the
time that it takes and you know some
founders doubt effectiveness and so we
tried to come up with a couple of
options out of the gate that were more
cathartic get the process started and
really introduce founders to a this
whole world of mental health help and
and so we chose carefully and so we
chose two solutions one is Meru health
which is a three-month platform it's a
hybrid of therapy CBT biofeedback and
CBT being cognitive behavioral therapy
which was what I studied in school and
there was the the the the paradigm of
therapy I thought was the most
instructive to me which is the thinking
about thinking how you frame things how
you interpret the world how do you speak
to yourself CBT cognitive behavioral
therapy maybe you could speak just them
for a moment about why that is so
effective for founder's because I do
think that that is I don't want to say
silver bullet but it certainly is in
some way I hear coming up over and over
again with therapy with wit founders
it's a constant I think of it as a
constant reminder a constant reminder
that you're going to be okay
now it's represented in many ways but
it's it's the continuity of of CBT that
I really believe creates the
effectiveness versus being in therapy
where it's just once a week you go to
therapy it's very helpful but between
sessions what happens nothing right
current typically but with CBT
especially when it's paired with therapy
you have this homework that's helping
you remember why you're in therapy what
your goals are reminding you that you're
okay and reminding you that you are a
good person and I'm giving I'm giving
you kind of a qualitative high
it's way more complicated yeah of course
we're not we could talk we could do CBT
for like there's there's somewhere out
there are seven podcasts about just the
subject but you yourself said you
reminded yourself and you were able with
your partner in life to say oh I'm
trying to grab the steering wheel right
now isn't that something I'm working on
it's like yeah you're working on that
you're a good person for working on that
that's an example the example I give
people is and I had to unpack this in
myself because people kept telling me
how delusional I was early in my career
and I unpacked it and I understood why
people thought I was delusional it was
because I attributed bad things to
random chance more Outsiders and being
unimportant and I attributed the good
things that happened in my life to my
explicit efforts that's interesting and
that it was not true right but if I got
pulled over by a police officer I didn't
I never blame myself for going a hundred
well anyway I won't say but I would
never blame myself for going very fast
on highways I just said oh you know what
these cars are so fast you don't even
feel the speed that's what I told myself
yeah you drive a Mercedes or a Tesla
that car just drives too fast it's too
tight on the road and you know what
everybody else was driving the same
speed so I'm just unlucky and you know
what
uh everybody gets to take it once a year
so that's if you just divide the 250
bucks it's like not even a dollar a year
ah not my fault when in fact it is
explicitly my fault my foot is on the
accelerator right right and that's what
cognitive behavior let me unpack is to
for me to understand hey where do I
tribute this stuff and sometimes people
I don't know if you do this or you've
seen this in founders they had a bad
beat and they just internalize it and
I'm like it's not your fault that
Microsoft decided to develop the same
product and make it free for everybody
that one wasn't your fault the pandemic
hitting is not your fault
but what you do have control over is how
you respond to those moments right
that's why I think CBT
so this program cost money thousands of
dollars I'm assuming yes who painted it
that's what we pay for it it's you know
it's about I think the commercial reads
about eleven hundred dollars for the
program yeah so it's a beautiful that
it's more affordable than thier
fantastic works it scales therapists
right in a way I think 7 X so you may
have which is which is for any sound do
you invest in can have this and you'll
pick up the tab correct I mean we just
anyone everybody to pause for a second
and think about that you know capitalism
you know and venture capital
specifically it's it's easy to attack
and make fun of on TV shows and Twitter
but we are we actually think about these
things and we actually take action and
specifically you're taking action now
what's the second thing you do it's
called the Hoffman Institute okay and
both Dave Jenni and I have all
experienced it it's a week-long
intensive terrier tear yourself down to
your studs kind of experience where the
sole purpose is to break the patterns
that you that you that started in your
childhood that are impacting you today
as an adult yeah it sounds intense it's
true I almost left after the first day
it was so intense but I for CH initely I
stayed and and it had a profound
experience